I don't know if you're aware of this but
Mayor Rahm Emanuel was was on this
program the mayor of Chicago was here
last night and today I find out you know
Andy does a credible mayor emanuel
impression yeah I figured if there's
ever a crowd that's going to appreciate
that Incredibles fare I didn't set the
bar too high there's no end before the
credible no no well I don't know I
haven't heard that Sanel it's like you
look the most like him go right so you
know you've played him and yeah I mean
I'll break off some Rahm Emanuel here
it's the key to it is it I mean he's the
reason we love ROM is because he's got
so much pent-up anger and you can tell
that all of the the things in society to
drive us crazy are also gnawing away at
him and he's just on the edge of
exploding
so I guess my rom would be something
like I'm doing my best to remain calm
and and work with the people of this
city but I will say this if you ever cut
me in line at the Wiener circle I will
rip out your larynx stuff it into a
sausage bun and feed it to my dog and in
case you're wondering my dog is a
euphemism for my
do not quit smack
that is how he talked to me backstage
yesterday let's talk about that's my boy
this is the movie that you've made with
with Adam Sandler and I got to see the
movie today and it's hilarious it's
really fun awesome thing yeah and you
guys are great together you play off
each other really well it's very unusual
you get to play Adams son son yeah yes
he in the film has a child as a teen
young team and is a terrible father to
me so when I turn 18 I basically run
away and then the movie takes place my
wedding week he shows up and he's kind
of a lovable dirtbag yes a very funny
dirtbag in this film we have a clip here
and you you wanted to play this part you
heard about the part before you even
read the script isn't that right that's
right I heard there was a part for a guy
to play Adam Sandler son if he had a son
when he was 15 and I was like what like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I considered it like a birthright so I
called him a bunch of times and begged
him and he was like he's like oh that's
nice we'll see if we do it I was like I
will cut off my left ball to be in this
movie and he was like well I hope
[Laughter]
we have a clip here from from that's my
boy anything we need to know for this
scene
I assume it's just rip-roaring funny
that's setup I've heard in a while let's
take a look at that's my boy did I do to
you to make you hate me so much I am bad
maybe you don't remember but you were
basically the worst parent ever me I did
everything for you buddy and I never
gave you an out about nothing never gave
me nothing I gave you a snake
yeah died after it ate all your Queens
there was the only time anybody's ever
seen a king cold brother alas
[Applause]